يصغر الحزن مع الوقت اما الكارثه فتكبر
وهؤلاء حزنهم محمول على كارهه تتقاذفهم
الام الفقد واهوال العيش فيناظرون عند
الانقاض طللا من لحم ومه في احد الايام
تخيل شاعر ما حدث لبنايه سكنيه ابتلعتها
الارض بقنبله فراغيه فراح يحكي عن سيده
تحت الارض تصنع القهوه وزوج يطالع صحيفه
تخيل حياه لا يراد محوها فما عسى تكون
ذاكره الجالسين فوق الانقاض الوان الاغطيه
وملابس النوم وتمنيات ليله سعيده لم تكتمل
خطط اليوم التالي المتحوله املا شحيحا
بعوده كانها قادمه من السماء
في اليوم الثامن الاف الجثامين لم تخرج
لتدفن ولم يؤخذ قرار نهائي بوقف البحث مع
استمرار رصد اثر لحياه هنا او هناك خصوصا
في تركيا حيث اخرج طفل وامراه مسنه
للخارجين كانه عمر جديد ولذوي المفقودين
انتظار قاتل لا يسكن بغير التسليم باقدار
الله وسننه الماضيه
بعد اسبوع لم يتغير في المشهد سوى زياده
عدد الموتى وهم يقتربون من اربعين الفا في
تركيا وسوريا
وتتحول الجهود اكثر نحو اغاثه الاحياء في
تركيا نزوح كبير من الولايات العشر
المنكوبه باتجاه الشمال ونداءات لتامين
الماوى والغذاء كاولويه للمنكوبين اما في
تلك البقعه المنسيه في شمال غرب سوريا
هناك حيث المخذولون والمتركون باعتراف
الامم المتحده فيتصاعد الالم ودعوات
الانقاذ لاربعه ملايين شخص وقد بحت
الاصوات تطلب الغوث فيدخل قليل شاحنات
للامم المتحده وفرق انقاذ عربيه لكن
الانكشاف الاكبر تمثل في تعامل العالم مع
تلك البقعه الجغرافيه وكانها تائهه لا
يعرف اين تحسب ولا كيف تدار لها معابر مع
تركيا تخضع لاليه دوليه ومعابر داخليه مع
مناطق سيطره النظام ولكل دوله كبيره مبعوث
فهذا مبعوث امامي واخر ام وثالث الماني
يدعون لادخال المساعدات ومع ذلك لا يدخل
سوى القليل لقد انتظرت الاسره الدوليه
اسبوعا لتفكر في اجتماع لمجلس الامن من
اجل غوثهم وحل مشكله المعابر المبهمه
بينما الاف تحت الانقاض وجرحى بلا علاج
ومشردون بلا ماوى
تقول المندوبه الامريكيه في الامم المتحده
ان الاهالي هناك يعتمدون علينا وقد فاتها
ربما انهم من يومهم الاول لم يجدوا غير
يدهم ليصفقوا بها لكن بدا هشا ومخاتلا ذاك
الاتكاء
في اليوم الثامن يسترجع كثيرون ثواني
الرعب مثل فاصل بين حياتين ستتكرر الايام
في تعدادها وتمضي الجرافات قريبا لرفع
الردم واخراج الجثث والرهان على احتواء
تداعيات الكارثه بعدما ظهرت نتيجه
الامتحان الانساني بسقوط مدون للاسره
الدوليه في ذاك المكان من بلاد تدعى سوريا